♪ Praise the Lord ♪
(drums banging)
♪ There ain't no need ♪
♪ Oh, ah ♪
- [Narrator] Aretha
Franklin, Beyonce, D'Angelo,
John Legend, Anderson Paak.
What do they all have in common?
Like countless other black musicians,
they've all gained their
foundation and love for music
through the black church and
the music it birthed, gospel.
♪ Guide my feet Lord ♪
♪ Prayers when I'm hungry ♪
♪ I've never eaten ♪
It's Sunday and I'm going to church.
I'm in Orlando, Florida at Live Church,
where Grammy winning artist
and gospel music star
Tye Tribbett leads the congregation.
(gospel music)
- Mainstream, secular, gospel,
everybody seems to come
through the church to like
hone their gifts, you
know 'cause that's a place
where a lot of people are accepted.
You can make mistakes and not,
cause you're not on TV reading charts.
You're just like trying to figure it out.
♪ Has more power than you ♪
♪ Nobody ♪
So many musicians that I know
literally came through GA and Soundcheck
actually that we see now.
♪ Nobody ♪
♪ Said nobody ♪
♪ Nobody ♪ ♪ Raise your book and say ♪
Music in the church is unconventional
and like I said, it's not charted.
You can kind of like
try things and be like,
weird, but it's okay
- It worked, I liked it.
- [Tye] Put the bass there, okay.
In the church, you can make those mistakes
that turn out to be
genius in another field.
(screaming)
♪ Who's greater than God ♪
♪ Nobody ♪
♪ Who's greater than Jesus ♪
♪ Nobody ♪ ♪ Who's greater than Jesus ♪
♪ Nobody ♪
♪Nobody greater ♪
(airplane engine)
- [Woman] LA and I are in Chicago
where the work of gospel pioneers like
Thomas Dorsey and Mahalia Jackson
gave rise to what we know as gospel music.
But the city doesn't only
hold gospel music's past.
Chicago gospel musicians
are constantly pushing
this great art form and
their skills forward.
- Definitely Chicago
is the home for gospel.
Hands down.
- Okay, so we in the right spot.
- [Donald] Yeah.
- [Narrator] So talk
about the black church
being a training ground for musicians.
- It's a training ground
but also too, everyone is so
on top of their skill,
when not really knowing the raw skill
is so great that it's like
singing at the Apollo.
(screaming)
♪ What's his name ♪
♪ Jesus ♪
- You have to be good, like,
you don't have a choice.
Or else, you just don't
get up there, you know.
So that's why some of the great singers
like an Aretha or like Whitney
or like so many came out of church
because we hear it all the time.
And it's others that you haven't heard
that probably equally as good
that you will never hear.
- [Narrator] True.
♪ Jesus ♪
♪ In the name of Jesus ♪
- I think the musicians
of this time, are so skilled.
Like they're incredibly skilled.
Their ears are not the
same but their ability
is like out of here.
It really is out of here, really is out.
I always tell 'em ya'll
make it too complicated.
- Yeah yeah.
- I always say you're overthinking,
it's not that complicated,
(laughing)
it's really just, you know,
two, three, six, five,
then back to one.
But you're trying to make it
like a thirteenth
- Like explosions (laughs)
- and then trying to expand it too much.
Like it's not that complicated.
(piano music)
(humming)
Right there let me show you what
they would do in church now.
The melody is,
♪ All that is within me ♪
Instead of going to (piano music)
Yeah instead of going to that 6th.
Right.
- Yeah.
(humming)
Exactly.
Then you go to the next chord,
the chord is there.
- That's the sweet spot.
♪ Is is ♪
- So who created black
gospel music? (piano music)
Many historians will tell you
it was Thomas A. Dorsey.
He's now regarded as the
father of black gospel music.
But Dorsey's career didn't
start out in the church.
Born in Georgia, Dorsey
began as a blues musician
and went by the name Georgia Tom.
He toured alongside blues legend
Ma Rainey, and wrote hundreds of
blues and jazz songs.
Some were a little risque,
like the hit he wrote
with guitarist Tampa Red,
"It's Tight Like That" from 1928.
♪ It's tight like that ♪
♪ Beedle-um-Bum ♪
- In the 1920s Dorsey had an epiphany.
He began to turn away from
secular music and started
writing gospel songs.
But he didn't leave his past behind.
He often infused his gospel music
with the feel and structure of the blues.
His gospel song, "If You See My Savior"
is swung and upbeat.
It follows a 16-bar
blues chord progression.
It has a steady 4/4 time signature
that you can easily stomp your feet to.
His lyrics, however, are
more hopeful and uplifting
than most blues songs.
Dorsey is offering a touching send-off
to someone who is about to depart
to the other side.
♪ Oh, tell them I am ♪
♪ Coming home someday ♪
- In 1932, Dorsey came here
to Pilgrim Baptist Church
in Chicago where he served as
Music Director for more than 40 years.
In 2006, this historic church
building was gutted by fire,
and the whole congregation
moved across the street.
(organ music)
♪ Through the storm ♪
♪ Through the rain ♪
♪ People walkin' in with Jesus' name ♪
♪ Though darkness overflowing ♪
♪ My Lord is nigh ♪
- That's one of the things
that made Professor Dorsey famous,
was that he combined the
blues and church music
and gave it that rhythm and swing
that a lot of people weren't ready for.
- Dorsey also employs call and response
in many of his songs.
An element in African music where
one phrase is the call,
and a different phrase is the answer.
Like in his song, "Never Turn Back."
♪ A long ♪
♪ Yes Lord ♪
♪ Time ago ♪
- Call and response is
historical from slavery times
because blacks could
not read at that time.
And there was always one
person around who could.
And they would read it,
and everyone else would
repeat it behind them.
- In the morning, when I rise.
Or I'm gonna lay down my burdens.
- Down by the riverside.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
Call and response is
integral to gospel music.
It can be found in secular music as well.
From artists like James
Brown to Kendrick Lamar.
♪ Sit down ♪
♪ Drank ♪
♪ Stand up ♪
♪ Pass out ♪
♪ Drank ♪
- Also in 1932,
Dorsey lost his wife and
son during childbirth.
This tragedy led him to
write what is considered
one of the greatest
gospel songs ever written,
"Take My Hand Precious Lord"
♪ Precious Lord ♪
Unlike "If You Meet My Savior",
"Precious Lord" maintains the emotion
of the blues without
adhering to its structure.
Check out Dorsey himself
performing the song
in the 1998 documentary,
"The Story of Gospel Music."
♪ When I look back ♪
- Just to see him, we stood in awe of him.
You know, that was history.
- [Woman] However, Dorsey
was not always celebrated.
- Professor Dorsey came,
actually from Ebenezer Baptist
Church where he started.
But they did not allow him to do his music
the way he wanted to do it.
So he left there.
And came to Pilgrim.
- He faced opposition for blending blues
and gospel with some ministers
calling it the devil's music.
- A lot of the old time church folks
were saying that he was
playing the devil's music.
That it wasn't of God.
- Well I mean, you can
liken it until today.
When we're doing hip hop.
And so, you know, a lot of old people say,
"That's the old devil's music."
No.
It's just a new style
that's come to us to give the Lord praise.
(organ music)
(clapping)
- Let's stand for prayer.
(laughing)
- God we thank you.
- Okay we're ready to finish, amen.
- As far as the blending of genres,
some people feel like it waters down
the gospel message.
- Message is words and sound is sound.
So I don't understand how you can take
a message down with sound.
I think more so religion does that
versus spirituality or even God,
because when God made music,
he didn't say, "This bass part is secular
"and this bass part is gospel."
We did that.
- Blending gospel and secular
sounds hasn't stopped.
Pioneers like Andrae
Crouch and Kirk Franklin
have been mixing gospel with everything
from funk to rock to hip hop.
♪ My brother can't you see ♪
♪ I've got the victory ♪
♪ Stomp ♪
It's this cross-pollination of genres
that makes gospel music
so adaptable to the times,
and why gospel musicians are so versatile.
We play it all.
♪ Everybody let's go ♪
♪ Rejoice ♪
♪ Rejoice to the Lord always ♪
Can you speak on how
your church has embraced
this new wave of music?
The shared exchange between gospel music
and secular music.
It's an exchange of influence.
- Mm-hmm.
♪ Lift your praise rejoice ♪
- It's like how my music
is outside of the church.
I think it's a little bit for everybody.
I think the biggest problem I had,
even at Sony Records,
was what category do we put this guy in.
Is this hip hop gospel, is this...
So we just coined this
phrase Kingdom Music.
♪ Again I say rejoice ♪
We didn't want to alienate anybody.
And we didn't want to
become elitist either.
It's very very broad.
You can get old-school tambourine,
chicken-eating feel.
- [Narrator] Church.
- Yeah, Hillsong Worship feel
when you just honor the Lord,
you know what I'm saying?
Or we can get straight street.
We embrace all forms of music,
so we can reach all forms of people
with one message.
- [Narrator] Indeed.
- I came from the shed, jam session thing.
I just had like sheds, just jam sessions
at the house all the time.
And from those pieces of grooves
that we locked into,
I wrote songs, like no way
came from a shed groove.
- [Narrator] Okay.
(Tye beatboxing)
(laughing)
- Come on man.
- He's ready.
- [Narrator] The term "woodshedding"
gained popularity among
jazz musicians in the 1930s.
It means to go some place,
like behind the wood shed,
to practice your skills
where no one else can hear.
(jazz music)
But in the early 2000s,
shedding became something new
thanks to Gerald Forrest,
the creator of a website
called Gospel Chops.
Originally, the website
was going to focus on
church organists and pianists,
before it shifted its focus to drummers
after he uploaded a video of Eric Moore
breaking down, what was arguably,
the first ever documented gospel chop.
(Eric Moore drumming)
In the mid-2000s, gospel
chops became a phenomenon.
Tony and Thomas' shed is arguably
one of the most memorable
sheds of all time.
Here, one can see those integral parts
of gospel music.
Tony and Thomas are responding
to each other's rhythmic calls
and are doing so on the spot.
(drum music)
- So a question for
both of you, basically.
I've never been to a shed session.
I'm not really sure,
I've since learned about it,
but I don't know what to expect.
What can I (laughs)
- [Narrator] Oh, it'll be a
vibe though. It'll be a vibe.
So it's like, I'll have the
quick tracks running in the app,
and I'll blast it
through the monitors
- [Donald] Wow.
- so everybody can hear
it, and keep up with it.
- [Donald] That's cool.
- [Narrator] Yeah.
- [Woman Narrator] And that's happening
at seven tonight, eight?
- [Narrator] We'll get there at 8.
- [Woman Narrator] How
many people are coming?
- [Narrator] I'm hoping,
I'm trying to make it
to the party.
- [Woman Narrator] Oh.
(drums music)
- [Narrator] For gospel
drummers like myself,
nothing sharpens skills
more than shedding.
(narrator drumming)
This is how shedding works.
There are two simple rules.
One, you establish a groove,
and two, trade solos
while keeping the one,
or the downbeat.
Locking in the groove
is an important step in shedding
because it gives context to all of the
chops, licks, and feels.
The groove is the template
that we all work within,
and it allows the trading
of solos to make sense.
(drum music)
Depending on the tempo of the groove,
drummers will solo for
either four or eight bars.
Four bars for slower tempos,
eight bars for faster tempos.
(drums beating)
(piano music)
What started as musicians
jamming after church services,
turned into a safe haven
for young black musicians.
(drums beating)
This adaptability continues
to push gospel music into
new musical territory.
(drums beating)
(piano music)
And in churches all across the country,
the next generation of musicians are
shedding their skills.
(drums beating)
Just look at Justin Wilson II,
better know as the drumming prodigy,
@babyboydrummer on Instagram.
(drumming)
(people cheering)
Here, he plays alongside
notable gospel musicians
Robert Bubby Lewis and Justin Raines
at the 2019 NAMM Convention.
The young drummer holds his own
alongside the other musicians
in what is essentially a shed session.
(drumming)
The exchange is a testament
to the black gospel church as a
training ground for artists and musicians.
(drumming)
What gospel music is and sounds like
continues to change.
But there's no denying,
that the black gospel church provides
a foundation for future musicians
who will one day,
share their gifts with the world.
♪ Greater, greater, greater, greater ♪
♪ Greater, greater, greater ♪
♪ Greater, greater ♪
♪ Greater than anything ♪
- But the gospel music industry,
I just, I mean, it's so open
it can be anything now.
I like that it's not just choir robes now.
It's so vast because everybody's not just
exposed to their lane.
Everybody's exposed to everything.
♪ Greater than anything ♪
- So there must be a culture
of working extremely hard
to get to that level surrounding
this community, right?
- I don't even know if
it's work to get there.
I think that because that's all you hear,
it just shows up.
- It's the, yeah,
you're around those church services
every day of the week.
- Yeah, like if you hear somebody
speaking another language
throughout your life,
then you speak it.
♪ You're greater than anything ♪
♪ We look up to you ♪ ♪
Where our help comes from ♪
♪ You're greater ♪
♪ Greater than anything ♪
- [Donald] It's just a
part of the community
so you just do it, you know?
You just learn how to dance
because everybody's dancing.
- [Woman Narrator] It's the norm.
- [Donald] It's the norm.
It's very much a norm.
♪ One more time say ♪
♪ He's greater ♪
♪ Greater than anything ♪
- Hey, give God glory in here.
(congregation clapping)